So that being said, with CAR-T, typically we have major side effects, which are cytokine release
and neurotoxicity, which initially resulted in prolonged hospitalizations, high utilization of
healthcare, and quite expensive. So if you think back to the timeline of CAR-T, in 2017, the first
commercial CAR-T was approved. In January of 2018, we began our outpatient CAR-T practice.
In March of 2020, we started our remote patient monitoring program. And then in about three and
a half years ago, we started a community paramedic program, which I will describe further.
Let's get through this. So the settings. So if you look at the schematic on the right,
number one is the Mayo Clinic. That is an eight to five clinic,
we see our consults, we see our day 30 returns. Number two, which is just above that,
is in the front of the hospital. It's the hospital-based outpatient.
That is where patients will come in daily. It is connected to the Mayo Clinic by
skyways and a subway. And then number three is where inpatient service is.
Number four represents the Gift of Life transplant house, which is about a half a mile
from the hospital and where most patients stay.
So again, laying the setting. Our remote patient monitoring system is a kit that includes a tablet.
It has a sphingomanometer that Bluetooths the data to the tablet. It's got a pulse ox,
a digital Bluetooth scale, and a thermometer. And then the community paramedic program. This
was established usually for primary and preventive care. But for CAR-T patients, we utilize it for
later time points for blood draws, to assess for transfusion needs, to do medical assessments.
They are under the guidance of a RIMS-certified hematology provider.
So what about the outpatient CAR-T practice? So we base this on our multiple myeloma model.
We've done over 10,000 transplants over the history of our transplant program.
But we looked at our day 100 all-cause mortality, and it was only 0.3 percent utilizing an outpatient
setting. So we thought we could do this with CAR-T. So the initial CAR-T consult is done in
the Mayo Clinic all the way up until lymphodepleting chemo, when the patient's transferred to the
hospital-based outpatient. And that goes through day 30. And then at day 30 onwards, it goes back
to the outpatient and Mayo Clinic. The cartoon on the right sort of shows the flow where,
you know, patients get their lymphodepleting chemo. They start their remote monitoring, and they're
done. And then it really is a flow back and forth with the hospital. The inpatient consultant
actually oversees the outpatient unit. We know that there are certain things that increase risk
for early hospitalization, including the need for bridging therapy, elevated LDH, et cetera.
So we looked at the first 120 patients. Eighty-five percent were infused as an outpatient.
About a fifth of those were never hospitalized.
Actually, a minor percentage was infused as an inpatient. Looking at the utilization of CARE,
I'll just point out the top line, and it's going against time, is where patients came
into the outpatient unit requiring nothing. No infusions, no electrolytes. Sorry.
Running out of time. So what about the remote patient monitoring? That, as I described, it's a
remote tablet, which uploads information. It is then transmitted to a remote nurse who is
monitoring the data. This is reimbursable. Medicare, Medicaid in 34 states will reimburse for
this. So in the cartoon on the right, the patient takes their vitals on number one.
It's uploaded to the cloud. And then in number three, it is evaluated
through an algorithm to determine if the patient needs to be seen
or not. So this is how it works. I'll show you a little bit of a picture of what this looks like.
So this is how it looks like. And then in number three, this is how it looks like in number four.
And then in number five, this is how it looks like in number five. And then in number six,
this is how it looks like in number six. And then in number seven, this is how it looks like in number
seven. And then in number eight, this is how it looks like in number seven. And then in number
eight, this is how it looks like in number seven. And then in number eight, this is how it looks like
in number nine. And then in number 10, this is how it looks like in number 11. And then in number
12, this is how it looks like in number 13. And then in number 14, this is how it looks like in number
14. And then in number 15, this is how it looks like in number 16. And then in number 17, this is
how it looks like in number 17. And then in number 18, this is how it looks like in number 19. And
then in number 20, this is how it looks like in number 21. And then in number 21, this is how it
looks like in number 22. And then in number 23, this is how it looks like in number 24. And then
in number 24, this is how it looks like in number 25. And then in number 26, this is how it looks
like in number 27. And then in number 28, this is how it looks like in number 28. And then in number
29, this is how it looks like in number 29. And then in number 30, this is how it looks like in
number 30. And then in number 31, this is how it looks like in number 31. And then in number 32,
this is how it looks like in number 31. And then in number 32, this is how it looks like in number
32. And then in number 33, this is how it looks like in number 34. And then in number 35, this is
how it looks like in number 34. And then in number 35, this is how it looks like in number 36. And
then in number 37, this is how it looks like in number 37. And then in number 38, this is how it
looks like in number 38. And then in number 39, this is how it looks like in number 40. And then in
criteria, which are listed below, they often would be admitted immediately. But the time from CAR-T to admission ended up being a median of 4.8 days. Whereas if they had routine criteria, which then said, you know, come into the clinic, be evaluated, that actually ended up with more quicker admission. I think that's what I got on there. And then what about our community paramedics? So the idea is that
we know that after day 14 and through day 30, you rarely see significant toxicity,
but you do often have transfusion needs. And so we can send the community paramedics out to the
patient where the patient is staying and have blood work taken to assess for transfusion needs.
They can do a physical exam. And if the patient needs, they will be sent into the outpatient unit.
We did look at patients who are enrolled in the community
paramedic program versus those who came in in the standard day 14 through 30 in the outpatient unit.
As you can see, there really wasn't, it triggered CRS in one patient out of the 21 in the community
paramedic program. So it does provide a benefit that you probably don't need all of the visits
into the clinic. Additionally, we weren't seeing an increased number of infections,
and these patients, you know, when the patients were admitted, it was a similar duration of stay
as in those patients that came through with no community paramedic. So key takeaways. So
an outpatient CAR-T hospital-based outpatient program is feasible. It's safe. It's probably
more cost effective. With the remote patient monitoring, you get additional data points that
may trigger a visit or an admission. And then finally, by incorporating a community paramedic,
you can reduce the clinical burden, all of the visits, the cost, and it is reimbursable.
So with that, I'd say thank you.